this case was simply an inquisition
there was a show trial and how it ended
is exactly perfect for that description
in that it didn't make a difference what
the jury saw what they said what they
discussed what they voted on at the end
of the day all that mattered was the
government's evidence no matter how
flawed it may have been no matter how
many lunatics and sociopaths and
Psychopaths that it depended on all that
mattered was the evidence and the jury
be damned all we had asked for at the
beginning was a fair trial I'm not here
to tell you that Joaquin Guzman is the
saint I'm not here to tell you that what
occurred that the witnesses were unusual
than any other American trial all we
asked for was fairness and no matter
what you think of Joaquin Guzman he
still deserves a fair trial everybody
does in America you can bury Joaquin
Guzman under tons of steel in Colorado
and make him disappear but you're never
going to remove the stink from this
verdict due to the failure to order a
hearing on the misconduct of the jury in
this case